[Applaudissements]
j'ai grandi dans france dans un village
du sud de l'alsace proche de la suisse
et de l'allemagne
enfant j'ai découvert que quand on
traverse l'une de ses frontières
beaucoup de choses sont différentes la
langue ou le dialecte qui est parlée
l'organisation de l'état les lois
beaucoup de choses en fait
la monnaie depuis ma maison en fait je
contemplais la vallée du rhin un fleuve
qui coule vers le nord en traversant
l'allemagne et les pays-bas mais
j'apercevais aussi la forêt noire ou à
moins de 50 km n'est le danube un fleuve
qui coule vers l'orient et qui finit par
se font dans la mer noire après avoir
serpenté entre la roumanie et la
moldavie
et si je regardais vers le sud
je voyais le jura le doubs s'y écoule
lui aussi à moins de 50 km c'est au
finissent dans le rhône puis dans la
méditerranée cette géographie liés au
village de mon enfance où le nord
lorient et la méditerranée sont si
étroitement intriqués presque
entremêlées m'a donné depuis toujours
l'idée de la richesse de la diversité et
dès le départ m'a donné le goût du
dialogue
aujourd'hui je suis neurobiologiste et
je travaille dans le domaine de la
dépression plus précisément de la
dépression dit résistante car elle ne
répond pas aux traitements traditionnels
j'essaie d'en comprendre les bases
biologiques et de proposer de nouveaux
traitements la dépression est une
maladie très fréquente car on estime
qu'une personne sur six en aura une
au moins une fois dans sa vie regardez
autour de vous parmi les personnes qui
sont situés juste à votre droite juste à
votre gauche où les trois juste devant
vous une au moins sera atteinte
peut-être vous même d'ailleurs d'après
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
la dépression est même la première
pathologie au palmarès pour le nombre de
jours
en bonne santé perdus du fait de la
maladie et son coût est énorme
il a estimé à 113 milliards d'euros par
an en europe ce qui à titre de
comparaison correspond à peu près deux
fois le budget de l'éducation nationale
chaque année en france
vous me direz mais ça soigne en effet
des traitements été découvert d'ailleurs
totalement par hasard à la fin des
années 50
aujourd'hui il existe une cinquantaine
d'antidépresseurs sur le marché mais
leur mécanisme d'action sont peu ou prou
les mêmes que ceux des molécules 10 à 60
ans en effet la communication entre les
neurones du cerveau se réalise en temps
normal
grâce à des agents des agents chimiques
appelée des neurotransmetteurs dans la
dépression certaines de ses molécules
sont déficitaires dans les zones du
cerveau qui sont engagés dans les
émotions et dans l'humeur et les
antidépresseurs viennent contrecarrer ce
déficit
les antidépresseurs ne guérissent pas
toujours la dépression en effet il ne
soulagent que 40% des patients
l'état des 60 % des patients restants ne
s'améliore que légèrement ou même pas du
tout si bien qu'il reste dépressif
malgré le traitement on les appelle des
patients résistants mais alors que faire
pour venir en aide à ces centaines de
millions de patients qui reste
dépressive malgré la prise en charge
pharmacologiques
il n'ya que deux solutions possibles
soit on modifie les antidépresseurs
existants soit on essaie de trouver
quelque chose de radicalement différent
on prête au physicien niels bohr qui a
été prix nobel de physique en 1922 la
citation suivante ne marche pas
ce n'est pas en améliorant la bougie que
l'on a inventé l'ampoulé électrique
transposer au monde des antidépresseurs
cela suggère que ce n'est pas en
améliorant les antidépresseurs existants
que l'on va trouver des traitements
efficaces chez les patients résistants
mais comment faire pour inventer un
médicament innovant qui serait aux
antidépresseurs ce que l'ampoulé
électrique est à la bougie
l'expérience que je vais maintenant vous
partagez témoigne du fait que
l'innovation se réalise quand on sort
des sentiers battus des chemins des
schémas tous fait des chemins déjà tracé
l'innovation survient quand on se met à
dialoguer avec des acteurs nouveaux qui
jette un regard différent sur le
problème et viennent donc les clarets de
manière inattendue en effet chez ces
acteurs extérieurs
ce regard n'est pas parasitée par des
schémas déjà pré existants ils peuvent
donc visité la problématique de façon
neuf et original
la première rencontre dont je souhaite
vous parler ici est celle qui a eu lieu
avec un philosophe de la médecine
maël lemoine qui est aujourd'hui
professeur à l'université de bordeaux
lorsque je lui ai parlé de la dépression
résistante
il s'est arrêté quelques secondes et il
m'a parlé de la fièvre
rien à voir a priori mais ce qu'il m'a
dit m'a fait revisiter totalement la
question de la dépression il m'a dit
qu'au 19e siècle avant que l'on ne
puisse établir un lien de cause à effet
entre des agents pathogènes et la fièvre
ont considéré la fièvre comme une
maladie et qu'il fallait donc prendre en
charge en tant que tel par la suite la
découverte d'agents pathogènes
spécifiques comme par exemple les virus
conduisit à revoir ce point de vue la
fièvre ne fut alors plus considéré comme
une maladie
mais comme un symptôme qu'il fallait
prendre en charge de manière différente
selon la nature de l'agent pathogène par
exemple tel virus provoque telle maladie
et toi donc c ra dickey de telle façon
et l autre c he added d'une autre façon
j'ai tout de suite compris ce que maël
voulais dire c'était facile de
transposer ça la dépression en effet je
suis convaincu que comme la fièvre la
dépression n'est pas une entité homogène
qu'il faut traiter systématiquement de
la même façon elle correspond plutôt à
différentes formes pathologique
différents sous types qu'il convient de
prendre en charge différemment l'inde et
des sous types est sans doute lié à un
déficit en eau ou transmetteur ce qui
d'ailleurs explique les 40 % de patients
répondeurs mais d'autres formes doivent
être prises en charge d'une manière
totalement différente de sorte à cibler
la cause qu'il a produit ainsi en
améliorant la bougie antidépresseurs il
est impossible d'améliorer la prise en
charge de toutes les formes de
dépression
reste alors à mieux comprendre
maintenant les causes possibles de la
dépression de sorte à pouvoir les cibles
et des psychologues comme pierre
philippe au mont alors décrit les
processus cognitifs qui sont
dysfonctionnels chez les patients
dépressifs et qui sont ciblés par les
psychothérapies on remarque que les
personnes qui souffrent de dépression
ont souvent un schéma de soi-même peu
valorisant une manière de percevoir et
de mémoriser tous négativement une
incapacité à freiner la rumination des
idées noires et une difficulté à traiter
les choses de façon précise pour moi
c'était le jackpot
en effet en tant que neurobiologiste je
sais que chacun de ces différents
processus est lié à des systèmes
neuronaux différents distincts les uns
des autres
on sait que le cerveau est composé de
différents réseaux fonctionnent elles
qui sont chacun spécialisé dans le
traitement de certaines fonctions tels
ensembles de neurones coopèrent pour
réaliser telle fonction est-elle autres
neurones coopèrent pour réaliser tel
autre fonction à ce stade on voit donc
clairement des correspondances entre les
processus cognitifs qui sont décrits par
la psychologie
et les réseaux cérébraux
dysfonctionnelle qui sont décrits par
les neurosciences et qu'il faut donc
ciblées pour améliorer la prise en
charge thérapeutique
les causes de ces dysfonctionnements ne
renault ensuite peuvent être divers et
variable par exemple il peut s'agir
d'une maltraitance durant l'enfance ou
bien d'une inflammation survenant à
l'âge adulte
en tout cas ce dialogue a permis de
dépasser le conflit qui parfois en pause
nos deux disciplines est de proposer un
modèle théorique conjoint maintenant que
nous connaissons les causes de la
dépression
il ne reste plus qu'à trouver des
traitement adéquat en réalité depuis
quelques années des techniques dites de
neurostimulation répéter permettent de
cibler les réseaux cérébraux précis en
vue de remettre en route ce qui serait
dysfonctionnel et ceci en administrant
des courants électriques ou magnétique
au travers de l'os crânien
on peut même acheter ce genre de
dispositif directement sur internet et
se stimuler le cerveau sans aucune
connaissance en euros anatomy ce qui est
tout de même a déconseillé vivement
malheureusement ces techniques ne
permettent pas d'accéder à des zones
profondes du cerveau elles ne peuvent
être utilisés que pour traiter des zones
superficielles elles permettent
d'atteindre les corses alors que le
dysfonctionnement est peut-être plus
profond si le dysfonctionnement concerne
une région profonde ce loi cela requiert
en général d'implanter une électrode
dans le cerveau qui va rester à demeure
dans le cerveau ce que les passions
refuse en général car personne ne peut
leur indiquer les conséquences à long
terme d'avoir une électrode dans le
cerveau en permanence en plus cela
évoque l'idée d'être un petit peu la
marionnette de la personne qui commande
l'électrode c'est une idée qui remporte
assez rarement l'adhésion des experts en
physique acoustique m'ont parlé des
propriétés des stimulations ultrasonores
qui permettent de délivrer de façon
répétée et focal des stimulations dans
des zones profondes du cerveau jackpot
avec eux nous avons décidé de tester
l'idée chez des souris dépressive et les
résultats ont été absolument incroyable
puisque nous sommes parvenus avec ces
stimulations répété à améliorer l'état
des souris bien sûr il reste du chemin à
parcourir pour tester cela chez l'homme
car il faut optimiser les paramètres de
stimulation mais les bases sont posées
et les premiers font également été
obtenu entre les médicaments et la
stimulation ultrasonores il ya en effet
le même écart contre la bougie et
l'ampoulé électrique
si la dépression n'est plus une entité
homogène contre est toujours de la même
façon
cela a également des conséquences sur la
prise en charge thérapeutique mais
également en économie de la santé dans
le domaine de la régulation du marché du
médicament en effet actuellement pour
obtenir l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché d'un médicament
il faut que le traitement soit meilleure
que ce qui existe déjà sur le marché
mais s'il ya plusieurs formes de
dépression
cette logique ne tient plus on se trouve
devant un marché totalement vierge pour
certaines formes de dépression pour
évaluer les conséquences sur le plan
économique
j'ai initié une collaboration avec des
économistes spécialisés dans le domaine
de la santé collaboration dans laquelle
je teste des nouveaux traitements et les
économistes calcul
l'impact en termes de remboursement des
médicaments je suis neurobiologiste mon
univers est celui du laboratoire d
observation du comportement des animaux
des techniques d'analysé du cerveau des
microscopes ma zone de confort se situe
autour des neurosciences et un peu
autour de la pharmacologie ou de la
psychiatrie mais comme vous l'avez
compris les découvertes les plus
fécondes et les plus inattendus que j'ai
pu faire son nez non seulement au
laboratoire n'est grâce au dialogue que
j'ai pu avoir avec des experts de
discipline différente de la mienne pour
favoriser ce croisement des savoirs mon
unité de recherche race
des chercheurs de quatorze disciplines
différentes la coopération et le
dialogue entre les philosophes des
psychologues des économistes les
physiciens permettent d améliorer des
avancées qui améliore la prise en charge
des patients dans le monde universitaire
l'interdisciplinarité est souvent une
forme dans l'incantation magique que
chacun invoque comme un sésame qui
ouvrirait toutes les portes
cependant si on ne va pas plus loin elle
reste sert il
mon expérience prouve que c'est
seulement quand on s'y confrontent de
manière réelle en risquant de perdre ses
repères et même sa compétence que
l'interdisciplinarité peut devenir
féconde et source de créativité
alan leshner l'un des scientifiques à
mirande américains les plus influents du
moment a prédit qu'en 2020 50 % de la
science serait interdisciplinaire 2020
c'est demain alors je vous invite dès à
présent à vous intéresser à ce qui ne
vous intéressent pas et à sortir de
temps en temps de votre zone de confort
pour regarder dans toutes les directions
le nord le rhin lorient le danube le le
sud de la méditerranée avec le rhône
mais n'oubliez jamais l'essentiel dans
ces échanges ce sont les personnes
le neurobiologiste le philosophe le
physicien le psychologue l'économiste
qui dialoguent pas les livres ou les
disciplines qui elle reste sagement
rangés dans leurs étagères je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]